summarizing documents can be a timec
consuming and tedious task it requires
careful reading analysis and it is easy
to make mistakes that could impact your
end users did you know there's an easy
way Google's gen AI document mization
the jumar solution it's a new tool that
uses artificial intelligence to generate
accurate and comprehensive summaries of
your documents Google's gen document
mization is different from other tools
in a number of ways first a use is a
state of RA model that is trained on
large corpos of tax
AKA this allows it to generate summaries
that are accurate and
comprehensive second it uses a variety
of technique to generate the summaries
that are readable and easy to understand
check the link in the description to
learn more about Google's geni document
summarization with jump start solution